la dernière fois qu'on a été vu en
public à laquelle vous avez vu passer
aujourd'hui sur le débat des chefs on va
revenir là dessus ça va être une grande
soirée
c'est vrai qu'on a même le décompte en
on vous pouvez voir le nom est
effectivement bon alors il ya c'est pas
le premier débat ce soir on se comprend
mais c'est le premier c'est le plus
grand groupe de presse qu'il organise ce
débat et c'est ça la grande nuance est
vraiment c'est la grande nuance on sait
que la formule habituelle des débats
cette année alors que pour cette
élection aussi n'existe pas été
chambardé quelque peu on a vu les
préparatifs au un studio 48 de radio
canada où aura lieu ce débat mais comme
vous le dites la grande nuance c'est le
fait que c'est un grand consortium le
plus grand jusqu'à présent organisé un
débat dans le cours de cette campagne là
évidemment radio canada en est un des
partenaires la presse télé québec
également s'ajoute à ça des médias
anglophones subi ici
citytv citytv et globo news qu'ils aient
eux aussi
si on veut diffuseront sur leurs
plateformes ce débat là alors c'est
véritablement à échelle nationale que ça
va se faire que ce débat les principaux
acteurs en ce qui concerne
l'organisation si on veut la tenue de ce
débat
anne marie dussault en tant que
modératrice yves boisvert et patrie soit
en tant que journaliste qui poseront les
questions directement chez bon et
presque failli inusité également dans ce
cas valent tous les chefs vont être là
tout cela ils seront à l'usom bien sûr à
ce qu'ont reçue à ceux qui ont une
représentation en chambre alors on les
voit ici et c'est la première fois que
ça va se faire dans un débat de cette
ampleur au cours de cette campagne de
cette campagne si l'ordre que l'on voit
ici marc andré paul l'ordre dans lequel
on l'y verra derrière leurs lutrins
respectifs tous a été décidé par vote et
celle hasard qu'il l'a voulu ainsi
justin trudeau sera l'extrême droite
suivi de madame et monsieur mais auquel
sera en plein centre une un emplacement
qui souvent très prisé simple sur un peu
on le voit ici tout juste avant
l'extrême gauche de monsieur
monsieur duceppe et puis si on venait
également sur la formule vous avez dit
on a choisi on se dit tirage au sort
il ya plusieurs façons de faire des
débats quelle est celle qui a été payé
une chose qui demeure toujours dans les
débats y ait des thématiques que l'on
sait blanc cinq grands segments liés à
cinq thématiques principales le
gouvernement service des canadiens
l'économie gouvernance démocratie et
institutions l'environnement et à ça
s'ajoute s'ajoute le canada dans le
monde hélas ce qui est intéressant dans
la formule mais voilà que voici comment
ça va se présenter il ya un hiver où
patrie soit de façon alternée qui va
poser une question un chef sur un thème
et ensuite le droit de réplique à un
autre chef tout ça des piges et au sort
et par la suite débat ouvert à cinq
reprises pour les cinq grandes
thématiques débats ouverts entre 5 et 7
minutes et ce sera là où anne marie
dussault va modérer tenté de rentrer
seul - cacophonique possible on connaît
les débats commencent à peu tourné
parfois choses intéressantes marc-andré
une petite innovation à la fin de chacun
de ses segments entre les segments des
questions rafale à chacun des chefs
l'ordre encore une fois été déterminée
par le tirage au sort 25 secondes par
chef pour répondre alors on va tester
certains de leurs réflexes qui disent
pas des pièges et mais quand même c'est
un élément intéressant qui s'ajoute à
regarder la tension où la tension
l'attention des chefs et des
téléspectateurs
bon mais je viens de dire
téléspectateurs justement je vous pose
une colle je suis dit travail à 8h on
est en auto on est on n'a pas de radio
on fait comment pour suivre le débat
il manque pas d'options finalement grâce
à radio canada toutes nos plateformes
bien entendu ben la télé pour ceux qui
seront prêts à la maison avec leurs
ailes de poulet aux prunes porte c'est à
vous de choisir
mais il ya ici r10 et radio canada dès
20h donc le premier rendez vous mais
c'est pas tout parce qu'il ya aussi la
radio de radio-canada qui va diffuser de
ce débat et sur le web c'est fort
important de le dire
diffusion sur nos plateformes également
diffusion sur youtube qui va donc
diffuser le débat sur sa plateforme leur
plateforme a eu et il y aura aussi une
vérification qui des faits qui se fera
en direct en temps réel sur une
plateforme web et toutes sortes de
discussion à laquelle vous êtes hockey
vous êtes conviés alors si vous êtes
friands politique
oui vous serez servi bon faut à la fois
j'écoute la télé j'écoute la radio et
puis la tablette est tous merci beaucoup
de tournois et ça m'a fait plaisir la
prochaine